hi welcome so my name is jung yong bum i
indeed live in the netherlands
it took me 14 hours on an airplane
without in-flight entertainment to get
down here so sacrifices you know I work
in Telenor it's like AT&T but the
Norwegian we're a big telco and it pay
me to work on open source so yes thank
you so in the past two and half years
have been mostly working with Mozilla
I've been appear on the Firefox OS
projects we've launched phones in
Eastern Europe and Southeast Asia and
lately I've been like focusing my
efforts on anything related with the
real world's Internet of Things robots
yesterday even built our rockets like
come on yes it went up extremely fast
and it went down like even faster but
you know like the fact that were in this
incredible ballroom with so many
developers that are all getting excited
by like playing with bots playing with
rockets playing with ships I mean that's
excites me man because it is one of the
best times to be in technology at this
moment we are on the verge of a new era
when I learned the program like in the
90s like if you wrote an application if
you wrote a computer program it
essentially meant that like it's running
this confined box if there's input
getting into the computer you did it
like over your keyboards and then when
it came out it came out of this play I
mean this is no longer the case like the
new programmer is is going to do this
like having a button and then like hello
yawn is gonna do this with like a real
breadboard and with a button and like an
LED display she's you cannot imagine
like how incredibly happy a was after I
got my Arduino
starter kits and I wrote some code that
made an LED blink you know like I was
like this you know like showing my mom
like hey mom you can type in your name
in your computer and then it like spits
your name back out and I've been not
been as enthusiastic as that about like
computers in a long time
and I finally like doing all this
hardware things that is what like like
gets me totally into this so we we can
take our coats out of this confined box
and into the real world and this is this
is a revolution that is just getting
started well we're we're nowhere near
yet we don't know what is going on or
how it's how it's going to end up but
like looking at like all these extremely
smart people one thing I know for sure
that this revolution is gonna be led by
JavaScript and I can imagine with you
guys are also incredibly tired like
three days of like full-on action so
today we're gonna we're gonna have like
a fun nice demo fool talk we're gonna
have audience participation yes real
audience participation isn't that cool
and we're gonna have a [ __ ] ton of gifts
so all right okay so the first thing
that I want to talk to you about today
is computer-generated music a a lot of
the music they would listen to today is
for a smaller or a bigger part is
already like kind of coming out of
computer like your drum loops might be
recorded you might sing something in and
then like add effects to it on your PC
there's like a group of people that take
this one step further and that's people
to do all girl raves now for me this is
this is like the nerdiest thing but it's
like nerds are like taking over the
world like really like a computer guys
standing in front of an audience like
life coding and then people start
dancing towards that man [ __ ]
so like three years ago or something
like LX Maclean's started this started
this movement and last year at Jess conf
Asia
I met a PhD from UCSB Charlie Roberts
who mended JavaScript environments for
all-girl ravers and it's essentially an
online IDE with a DSL that allows you to
write codes and and like make people
dance Siddhant it's like for electronic
music so let's say I don't want to make
a beat all I need to do is a is drums
and then just be so you just put it on
bit up now just like basic is pretty
cool I mean like it took me six years or
something to like get this out of a
normal drum kit and I can do it one line
of j/s we can also add like a little
[ __ ] to it so you can like like play
around with like variables pretty cool
there's like a lot more you can do the
faux coding so for example here is like
with our own jazz song now if you look
closely at this they actually see that
there is like a whole number of
variables in this code and this is a
parameters that directly influence the
music if you set the pitch of the drum
we get like an actual different sound
and look for programmers this is amazing
you know if you're standing there in
front of an audience you can like play
around with the parameters the only
thing is like it's very static you know
once you pick one it's that's basically
it it does that's what it's gonna be
so then then I thought like what else do
you see at concerts these days like way
too much mobile phones and mobile phones
are now pretty good at like capturing
what's happening around you because
mobile phones have sensor sensor sensors
as sensors
so today we're gonna do a nice little
experiment where you guys are going to
help me produce some music because we're
gonna use the sensor data of all your
phones and I've no clue helmet how many
phones the computer is going to be able
to handle this all get uploaded to a
node.js iOS server and then we feed the
day that like the data from all of you
together into a music generating
algorithm so you guys have influence
over how the music is going to sound
today if you want to like play around
with it later or if you like a cool
algerie like this code is on get up so
you can integrate it so instead of
setting a set variable for the pitch we
can get like the yo off or the pitch of
all your phones and then feed that into
the algorithm so when people like start
moving around their phones music will
actually change here's a variable okay
so they'll one that's one of the demos
that we're going to do today another one
because your mobile phone is still
really confined by like what the sensor
can detect the gyro meter or
accelerometer but now that we have new
things Bluetooth beacons I got a number
of them here they're incredibly tiny
chips they don't run JavaScript
unfortunately but they just broadcast
their existence I can put one here on
the wall and for the next two years
we'll just say hey I'm here I'm here I'm
here I'm here
they're getting tiny this is the new
generation of these estimates like over
$10 look tiny small you can like
broadcast a value like a URL or sensor
values now the cool thing is that the
ability to detect beacons to like walk
into a room and then see like okay
there's like 10 around you in five
meters it's coming to JavaScript
we actually we finished implementing
this in Firefox OS and we hope to bring
it to Firefox 4 end rights like on short
notice
alpha Tunes gonna come from behind the
flag and like be accessible so have
phones that actually run this I'm gonna
do some demos with that how you scan for
beacons it's pretty straightforward on
the most blue thing it's not
standardized yet but in the in the web
Bluetooth standards we're talking about
implementing low-energy support for
Bluetooth so this is also coming like to
the standard track we can get the
adapter start a low-energy scan in this
case we're not interested we're
interested in all the devices around
this and then when a device is found we
get an event a couple seconds later we
can stop the event you get contains the
scan records and that basically is all
the data you send it
most things currently follow the ibeacon
standards from apple and that gives you
three IDs essentially a UUID for
manufacturer a major and a minor so
that's how you can like detect which
beacon is what now what are we gonna do
it is today the javascript baby monitor
so you gotta tech we're gonna tag a baby
with a phone then on the phone we run
some JavaScript but constantly searches
around for the beacons then based on how
strong the signal is we're gonna
triangulate from the three beacons with
some math and that way we know we're in
a room the baby is located now you might
think like taking a baby with a phone is
that really necessary on a J's gonna be
you I presented a project called yawn OS
that allows you to rip apart the main
board of your phone and like take your
baby with that instead so you can make
like a child-friendly device I'm not
gonna talk about that today like let
let's see how this looks like we have a
baby we position three beacons around it
and then we tagged the baby with a
seaport
now we basically know like how far from
the beacon we are because we get signal
strength so if we combine the data from
three beacons we realize that where it
is like intersect that is where baby has
to be and then when the baby like runs
away then we can start doing alarm
pretty simple right all in JavaScript so
demo time if like if you're on the JSE
own track a Wi-Fi network then get
yourself over two one nine two one six
eight one five seven eighteen port nine
three two one
I guess that is where the magic is gonna
happen so what you're gonna see in your
screen is essentially a dot and this dot
is getting influenced by the way that
you like rotate your phone in physical
space so I'm gonna go to my command
center so here we have all the people
around we have ten people connected and
we're getting like the data from all the
phones averaging it and like the way
that you pitch it it's bad and I'm
basing that we can make some music so if
you all have phone like this we should
be able to let go exactly in the center
okay and now I want to like move it like
to the left top corner so it's ROI like
change your phone like in physical space
to the left top corner
and there's so many people connected now
so one person is like doing it like okay
get over there like like see how the
music changes you feel a lot of music
chains a little bit like depending on
like how high or how low the thing is
like we have we have echoing and pitch
and it's always hard to do audience
participation in this thing so my score
is completely going berserk on this I
can I can show you how it works it like
just one person because totally not how
they thought it would work so connecting
myself to my own network and then go to
the page okay so now it's just me and
when I move it
you can get like free free ratification
echo it so bad like start beeping it's
not fun for anyone now this is just one
thing we can also do this with with
visuals so now when I so based on like
how high anything is the BPM is
dependent so now it's like nice and
relaxing and if you move it all the way
over here you change like how the music
like feels more rich or faster pretty
cool like with all these people would go
even better but they didn't test it more
and then now we have two BPM so what we
can now do is add some extra magic to it
so here's the code they have full screen
essentially what we can just write is
like get a drum sequence then the
amplitude is like based on data to get
from the phone and the BPM is based on
other data that we get from the phone
now I made the thing that that part is a
gift and then can dynamically like
change the speed of the gift based on
like how fast the music is playing
and that nine out kind of like itll is
slower or we can't like go and make
completely crazy alright so that was
what does the music now I'm gonna let
the let the music play a bit and then
I'm going to set up my my beacons so
let's say that this is the area so let's
say that this is the area where the baby
is allowed to go so I'm putting a light
blue beacon here so I measure this for
is like a bit over three meters which is
in United States measurements I think
like eighty one point four stones so we
have three here and now let's go to the
rights page
so this is where the data is gonna come
in so I'm gonna put the phone here just
to make sure that we getting the data
and little whenever the data is now
coming in and will redraw so we connect
it and data should start flowing so as
you can see the that how big the circle
is like depends on where I position the
phone so now we're just waiting for the
data from the mains beacon which is the
one here it really varies at this point
and that's because we get like the wrong
value and the wrong value is really
dependent on like a lot of factors so we
can buffer the RSSI and then it will
slowly then over like remove all the
drifts and we get like a better
positioning you can also like draw the
intersections and based on that we can
get the average so if I move the phone
or baby to for example here you can see
that like the actual position that we
detect like is actually getting there if
I start moving the thing around luckily
enough babies are not very fast so it's
okay it like takes a couple of seconds
if I'm moving in here then you'll see
that the position of the orange dots
will start to change we cannot do this
and like if the baby gets out of the
bounding box then it's Vegas out of the
bounding box we can sound an alarm or
like do something about that so we're
here and now you see it like you see it
moving towards the purple one now I
figure like okay that's pretty cool but
what if you could like listen to baby
generated music
so we're gonna open the baby thing and
we're gonna apply the the data that we
gets out of here like the position of
the baby in a physical space and feed
that into music generating algorithm so
the idea is that like whenever the baby
is like in this space where it's allowed
to go then like everything is all right
I mean we don't really have to play like
big-ass crazy music I'll be do it we got
a fisherwoman thing okay but now what if
the baby starts to escape you know
they'll be disturbing for some reason a
ton of Mynt yet so I'm gonna restart the
application with them so when the baby
escapes we can change the BPM of the
music like a lot so hey we need to check
out something just crazy stuff is
happening so here we go
so relax and let's see if I run away
fast enough if you can have something
you think because the mint one just
stopped working
thank go like if necessary just go to
the pizza guy see okay music yeah fast
like we need it like act on this [ __ ]
now thank you
alright let me close that thing off and
get back to my slides now we have ten
more minutes you know and I figured I
always wanted like a real like one more
thing moments so I mean I've been
working on Firefox OS own like a variety
of plaster and I would like focusing on
the Internet of Things
the thing is Firefox OS is not just
about phones anymore it's about
televisions tablets like things that can
run it but we also want to like bridge a
gap to the physical space and for that
we invested in a number of technologies
including blo Bluetooth Low Energy
Virtual Reality
with Firefox VR but also WebGL which
allows you to get a video streaming and
starts detecting stuff on that and from
that premise we started thinking you
might like it what if we would design
wearable running Mozilla technology if
we figure that the beacon stuff would be
incredibly useful because if we for
three dollars can get like a beacon like
straight from the factory and tag that
at like interesting places or tag it to
people it would allow us to like augment
your reality like based on where you're
physically are in the world walking
rounds of course this also has to be
built on open standards and today you
guys are going to see the very very very
first wearable that Mozilla has been
working on like right here on Jay s conf
like a couple minutes before the end
freaking exciting so the first wearable
that that we together like wit Mozilla
and a bunch of partners have built is
Mozilla glass
and I got it with me actually here today
so we looked at like what other
variables are around at its points and
we we had like a number of of things
that we required so first of all we we
wanted to work with any type of glasses
prescription or sunglasses doesn't
really matter the the prototype that we
have here is mounted on the glasses that
you got in your goody bag I mean it's
the affiliate if they t-track or what
the company is called and the glasses
were from the same brand we also want
that would be a standalone product no
x-ray device required there's a voice
control to get like information without
like always looking at your screen and
the self LP a self built kit is going
for about three hundred US dollars are
you ready all right first thing we'll
see like glass hand-built by me
so what we see here and I got one with
me you're gonna demonstrate in a sec we
have a camera module on top on the left
we have the display and sensors the
these to talk with each other over a web
RTC connection to get the data from the
camera into your corner and then we have
a small little mirror in the in the
inner side of your glasses so you can
like look a bit to the right and get the
image from your display on the left
alright so for this for this next
segment I need to have Steve Keeney
Jacob Ruffa and Chris Williams on stage
because they're gonna help me with this
thing
so guys run up to run up run up all
right hello my beacons okay mm-hmm oh
you're gonna be Chris Williams okay so
and I need you guys like okay we're what
we're gonna do is it's like a party you
know here and like these RP and I want
to know like who do I have to talk to at
parties you know I want to be like the
cool guy that like always knows the
subject to talk to and people think
you're interesting that is can we do
today so let's say that we tagged all
these people with beacons Steve gets ice
Jacob gets blueberry and you get means
and I meet you guys like be like a bit
socially awkward and stand by yourself
at a party so look like not super not
too close to each other please now yeah
a bit like like near the stage please
I'm gonna go to so the beautiful thing
is because I party see that gets of the
camera we can also get like a live feed
here up the up the screen go there
lucila class as you can see we're not
connected to anything here I am going to
this is gonna be my camera clients
so here we go yeah and here we got the
Colossus let me just verify that we're
still connected yeah you know hardware
is a lot of fun I'm so hoping that on
Twitter like like people will like go
completely crazy like we're bolts so
we're connected I don't see any beacons
yet but that is going to come so I'm
gonna place this on my head I'm gonna
connect to my camera module here so I I
ran out of duct tape so the moment that
I connect to this thing we should start
seeing a video stream here okay so here
we are now of course we have voice
controls as well and for ah wait that is
so we have voice control as well we
partnered with andreas gal the CTO of
Mozilla to do the voicing I want to
Brendan Eich but you said as Taylor
Swift do you guys get a streamer okay so
let me full-screen this thing yeah you
know it's pretty hard to see with these
glasses on
oh okay so back to the thing okay so
here we are back on the stream need to
have some sensor data out of here as
well would be nice because now it now
you can ask my voice assistant to come
onto stage
hello Andreas can introduce yourself
hello from Mozilla class I am Andrea
scow
CT Mozilla because we of course also
care about like other companies that are
working in the same space like Google we
have three right now I really need to
get some assistance I mean I can say I'm
Reyes call me Google ok Google isn't
that nice all right can you starts the
this you know this worked so well in my
head yeah okay yeah okay so yeah you can
you can hold on yourself so we're going
to get the video stream back at this
points I mean it looks pretty good on
you like to be honest okay so now let's
let's do the augmented reality thing and
I want you to walk over there where do
you have to beacon so this is supposed
to be okay so get a bit closer you need
to be like in close proximity you mean
we're at a party here
wait so whenever it is works this is
like always the good thing to have like
a backup glass not mount its to like
real glasses so here we go Steve Keeney
information
this is open-ended reality guys now and
as you can see the moment that we walk
away like in immediately the information
disappears as well we can do this the
same thing with Jacob here yeah oh that
will be nice so what can we talk about
with you today you know I can talk about
the cure or if we can talk to Kris
Williams Tacoma everyone knows him well
you know like oh hey I just thought I
should mention that you might not want
to put that drug battery in your check
luggage all right
so it can also tell you like based on
the voice commands for your near we do
oh you're not near anyone so I'm not
there anyone or and is like the coolest
feature it can also shoot laser beams
I'm sorry John
I'm afraid night long too hot okay so
here's the thing we cannot predict the
future you know it's it's 2015 where the
hell is my overboard actually after like
yesterday's event with the note copters
we decided we no longer want hoverboards
we want quad copters or like drones that
can carry people like way cooler we
can't predict the future
but one thing we know for sure and I
hope that today's demonstration even
though it was a bit flaky at times it's
like a demonstration of that and like
the whole Jas cone thing and this is
like the thing you have to take home
from all of this we can't predict the
future we do know that a large part of
that is going to be written in
JavaScript and with that why 30 minutes
are rough and I really really want to
thank you all for being here and thanks
for such a great conference